uncover and explore who you are through
creative writing prompts with the
pursuit of WGU guided Journal all the
ways things could go the link is in the
description you've never felt like you
could be yourself around me she said
with a confused and mildly frustrated
tone her face was both clenched with
irritation and drooping with sorrow her
brow pulled in while her mouth and
cheeks fell out and down as she looked
over at me lying stiffly in the hospice
bed she looked like she was about to cry
but she hadn't given in yet I felt like
a virgin I answered what does that mean
a version her tone was even tenser now
just not my whole self I guess not who I
really am whatever that means at this
point then why the hell did you marry me
she said between the stir craziness of
the last nearly 2 years the medications
having been in the hospice center for
the last 3 weeks and of course the
looming finality of everything I had for
the first time in as long as I could
remember perhaps in my entire life
suddenly felt the walls come down I
couldn't hold them anymore more so I
just didn't care to it's not that I lost
care altogether I still cared a lot it's
just that I stopped caring about the
things that didn't matter at least not
to me not anymore I didn't care about
being perceived in a certain way I
didn't care about being consistent I
didn't care about how well I played
along what other people expected and
wanted of
me my doctor had said that my chances of
making it passed one year after my
diagnosis were very low given the state
of my condition now over a year and a
half later I felt like I was basically
living free extra days in a way my life
felt like it had ended on that onee Mark
I felt like I was a ghost who only
haunted himself I saw myself almost as a
carcass of Life of regrets yet still
filled with the spirit of who I really
was who I had always wanted to be I felt
separate from everything yet still
present it was one of those strange
States that's impossible to translate to
anyone who's never been in it never
outlived their own death I looked at
Kate I've never felt like myself with
anyone I told her I didn't mean you
specifically you didn't do anything no
one did it was my fault what do you mean
John she said her tone loosening and
opening up a bit I blew it I did so much
wrong Kate leaned in closer toward me
shifting her hand a bit inside mine I
looked up at the ceiling what are you
talking about everyone loves you John
everyone I've ever known that knows you
that's spent time with you loved you
loves you I looked back over at her her
face was softer now stretching
vertically rather than scrunching
horizontally she realized this wasn't
about her or
us my whole life I was so worried about
whether or not people liked me loved me
I did everything I could to ensure that
everyone did that everyone thought I was
the greatest oh John is so great he's
this and he's that I changed so much
about myself to make sure that happened
in moments in phases in years I always
went this way instead of that way to
ensure that I did what people wanted
that people approved of and liked me I
cared so much about how I was
experienced in the minds of everyone
else that I never even really
experienced me in my
own there was a long pause John that
just makes you a good person you put
others first it's in your nature it's a
good thing her voice was shaky is it did
I there was another pause my head was
hurting I felt weak and tired and
slightly numb I felt a strange Lucidity
amidst the disorientation though Kate
just sat there
waiting I cared about how people saw me
I continued I cared about how they
experienced me it was all always about
me not anybody else well who the hell
else is it going to be about Kate
interrupted of course everything you do
from your perspective is going to
involve you no I didn't even really care
about me either that's the worst part it
was like a a strange Paradox of
narcissism and self-abandonment I was so
desperate so misguided so self-focused
on being liked and seen a certain way I
changed and reduced who I was at every
turn to appease my father mother friends
teachers girlfriends bosses strangers my
wife that's not a good person it's not a
bad person it's just not much of a
person at all Kate's eyes began to water
then so did
mine
she said to me you did what you could
you did what you knew how that's all
anyone can do I paused for another
moment I looked out the room's window at
the cars and people rushing by on the
streets below a city of people
frantically completing to-do lists that
weren't their own I was so worried about
being seen as a perfect person someone
who was successful who was happy who was
always fun to be around who was smart
and competent who did the right things
in the right way and now I'm going to
die ey without having really been seen
by anyone at
all I could hear Kate sniffing I looked
back over at her she was pulling tears
back in they looked
heavy okay she said defiantly while
rubbing her face then talk to me now she
continued let me see you be who you
really are there's still
time use
[Music]
it
thank you so much for watching one of
the most important things we can do in
life is try to understand ourselves this
of course can be extremely difficult and
convoluted often times without any clear
answers at all but with the right tools
time and effort we can get a bit closer
to some semblance of answers I created a
guided Journal designed to help with
this process called all the ways things
could go it uses creative writing and
drawing prompts that help you explore
your subconscious mind and arrive at
clearer self- understanding rather than
starting with a blank page with this
guided Journal you're given
thought-provoking prompts designed to
stir your creativity and coax out inner
thoughts and feelings that might
otherwise be hard to access for example
on page 50 you're given the prompt write
your obituary this is intended to
challenge you to consider yourself from
a different vantage point in this case
after you're gone almost tricking
yourself into writing a guide for the
type of person you want to be when all
is said and done it gets you out of the
way so you can better see who you are if
you're interested the link is in the
description
below and of course as always
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next
[Music]
video